welcome
how to ebb and flow from
the physical to the absolute
again these two are ultimately one
yet we are creating a juxtaposition and
a
spectrum for our
self inquiry
for our self-realization
for our god realization
as you've probably been able to tell
this is
quite physical
and it's quite gross
that spectrum is from the gross to the
subtle
so this physicalism
typically the
egoic separate entity
the contraction of consciousness
into this tightly
constricted
fist and body
ah
let's go
it's the most simple exercise that we
can do
to understand the movement from the
egoic i am the body
having this experience
which i used to also think that i was
the body having this experience
i had never understood what the i
am was let alone the absolute
i thought i was a separate entity
i was attached to all of my onion layers
of identity
cravings aversions
seeking happiness exogenously outside
externally
but happiness and the separate entity
are mutually exclusive positions
over time the contracted
ego which if you just tighten up
with me in a practice just tighten up
your fist
and tighten up the core of your body
keep it tight and then
relax and loosen it
ah melt
ah melt
that's the most classic release
and expansion of
the egoic separate self
which believes that the body is having
the experience very
analogous also to a sugar cube
that dissolves in the
hot tea
in this case we become a lot more subtle
when we make the juxtaposition to that
i am
again all of this is ultimately one we
are showing how to ebb and flow
from that egoic to
the i am to the absolute
in order to create more clarity in
self-realization and self-inquiry
in order to show more of the map and
more of the paths
up the mountain to the one truth
of the absolute
you can call it the one infinite creator
you can call it god you can call it
source you can call it
in this stage the i am
and what we mean by the i am and you can
watch
all of our other videos on the direct
path to get
a better taste for this
is we simply mean you become the witness
of the experience so in the
analogy
the most common way for the egoic
separate entity to
be misled
is to believe that it is
in the analogy of the ocean and the
waves
the egoic separate entity believes
that it is alone just the wave
it is the wave or in the analogy of the
sky
and the clouds
it believes that it is the clouds
it has yet to taste the sky it has yet
to taste
the ocean or in our
other very common analogies it's
caught up in the words
on the paper
or it is caught up in all of the
applications on the device
now once
that contracted
it egoic separate entity
relaxes that constricted feeling
it gets this release and an expansion
because it begins to understand it
tastes the
ocean it tastes the sky
it tastes the blank paper
it tastes the blank screen
so now we're beginning to feel
as though we are more of a witness
we are more of that i am-ness
we are no longer solely
the clouds or the waves or the words or
the applications
but we've created a juxtaposition where
we recognize ourselves
as the blank screen as the blank
paper as the blank ocean
as the blank sky
and that that is eternal and that
is infinite it's been here before
it'll be here after we've been doing
this we're going to continue doing this
that its nature is bliss
and peace
and that it's eternally being colored
or modulated by the clouds by the waves
by the words
by the applications by the
thoughts emotions experiences
beliefs feelings objects
our subtlety increases massively
from the egoic to the i am
when we create that juxtaposition we
gain a lot of subtlety
we recognize that the awareness itself
is shared among all 8 billion of us
that awareness is shared and even beyond
this creation design
and that is the tasting as well
of the non-dual awareness that is
the light flickering
the more the separate entity of the ego
dissolves and the more that the
oceanic-ness the sky
the paper the screen
is made home
the more the light moves from a state of
flickering to a state of
staying on
that is enlightenment
that is awakening that is piercing the
veil
that is self-realization
this is the most important thing for
society to do is to self-realize
once you understand that our being
as that awareness is shared
that is love and
the absolute highest begins
channeling through to express itself in
society
absolute highest morality absolute
highest ethics
absolute highest creation absolute
highest
meeting basic needs absolute highest
enabling others to flourish
absolute highest well-being and
abundance and prosperity
and harmonization with the living
original vision and wisdom of the earth
self actualization without self
realization
is blind
it's seeking happiness
and fulfillment
and cravings and aversions
in the external
and then we wonder why we have moral
lapses in judgment it's simple
self-realize first and then you have
none of the downstream issues
and again on a hyper macro level on the
level of the absolute
there are no issues it's all just
indescribable perfection
but we're creating these juxtapositions
and these spectrums to give us more
clarity and insight
into self-realization into this
enlightenment awakening and ability to
ebb and flow
between the physical and the absolute
if you're here at this stage of
the i am the witness
of this experience if you're at the
stage where you're
realized as the ocean as the sky
as the paper as the screen
congratulations that's huge
and also
you're likely undergoing a process
especially if the
light bulb is flickering
or even if it's really staying on and
the ego has completely dissolved
that in a sense you're learning how to
ebb and flow
between the i am
and the wave
or the cloud
the ebb and flow between the oceanicness
and the wave
takes some time to get used to
i'm also going through a similar process
myself of getting more and more
comfortable with the indescribable
perfection of
every single wave that we're surfing
hella fun definitely not
fighting the wave
that's what happens with the egoic
separate entity it fights the wave
the i am learns how to be the witness
of the experience of the serf
this is a huge step up in
subtlety massive
step up in subtlety
again the experience
is as simple as contracting yourself
with the clenched
fist and a clenched body
and then
do with me and then relax
that analogy and metaphor that
rupert spira passed along has been
extremely
salient
okay so the subtlety increases great so
we've recognized that we share our
awareness our consciousness
our knowingness with the other eight
billion and you can tell
by the pupil you look at the pupil
the pupil is that awareness that
consciousness that knowingness that is
shared and that unique iris
is the unique wave the unique
cloud the unique words
the unique application that is being
explored by that
iris but the pupil
the pupil
is the shared awareness the shared
consciousness
the shared knowingness
so that requires a big leap in subtlety
and so again it's huge if you've
made moves towards that again
self-realization
first to make sure that
self-actualization
is not blind
and that's also going to lead us into an
explanation on this next level of
subtlety towards the absolute
which has been interesting
for me to explore
so if you're already in a state
of i am
if you're already in a state of the
oceanic-ness of the witness of the waves
join me there
become aware of that breath
okay so the i am-ness
of the ocean experiencing the waves okay
so we're here now again look at how
relaxed
this is
looked at how relaxed this is compared
to the
jittery separate entity of the ego
stay aware of the breath
again the witness the i am
okay so now we're gonna take a jump in
subtlety
i want us to decline the fact that we
are the i
am i want us to
go even further back go
even further beyond the observer
beyond the witness go beyond the
observer
and the witness go beyond the i am what
is there
what is there and stay there
stay there
hold the formlessness
hold the agentlessness
no agent
hold the attribute attributelessness no
attributes
hold it
stay in the indescribable perfection
stay there
ah
no agent no attributes
no form
just indescribable perfection
the absolute
okay so
that is on the spectrum
of hyper subtlety
that's typically referenced to as
there is no one here doing
anything
as you can tell when you're there
which is nowhere
what's happening is a
all observation all witnessing
all i am-ness
has been transcended
the experiencer and the experience
so the ocean of the experiencer
and the waves of the experience
have been transcended into a place
of indescribable perfection
which this is
and words themselves
struggle with the ability to
explain the indescribable perfection
and that's why we use
the words unconditional love
and so to work on that subtlety from the
i am and then to
transcend even the observer
even the consciousness or awareness
itself to a place
that is agentless so no agent
attributeless no attributes
formless no form
just indescribable absolute
perfection
now
i'd love to hear from you in the
comments
where you are at in this spectrum
which is ultimately only one
and we're just creating this spectrum
in order to showcase
said map of self-realization
it's helpful to honestly know
where you are at here in this
self-realization
where you are at determines where you
are naturally
doing repetitions
to continue on that self-realization
for example for me
i'm really working on the subtlety
right now the subtlety
as the i am
witness to be able to
ride
the waves to surf those waves
with imperturbable peace with causeless
joy
with bliss with equanimity
with love with wisdom with grace
with compassion
and then that becomes so
natural that becomes home
is just the constant peak of the wave
just simply this
simply this
indescribable perfection simply
this indescribable
perfection
simply this
indescribable perfection
it becomes an absolute indescribable
perfection
that words miss and then the subtlety
picks up
because
the idea and experience
that is a perennial wisdom
is that there is beyond
the observer beyond the consciousness
beyond the witness beyond the i
am
is a formless agentless attributeless
indescribable absolute
and so then the process is to undergo
that subtlety even more subtle
than the i am-ness even more subtle
even more subtle
and then even the agent itself
of consciousness of the witness of the
observer itself
becomes agent less becomes attribute
less
becomes formless
that's why it said there's no one here
doing anything
now there are times when the egoic
separate entity will
say that they've become the witness
or that they've they realize that
no one's here doing anything
it is said
to express the way that consciousness
wants to withdraw itself
from the contracted entity
of the separate ego and
become what it already
naturally is
the sky the ocean
the screen the paper
and that's why the egoic consciousness
makes such
claims
it has a seeking
impulse that is the truest thing about
it
five years ago in 2015
i was playing clash of clans
on three accounts simultaneously
today i consider myself enlightened
awakened having pierced the veil having
self
realized and it
took a lot
i dedicated myself to truth above
everything like a full-time job
and that's why it yielded
all of the latticework
of all of the different perennial
wisdoms across
the mystic traditions of the planet
you can imagine reading dozens of times
the i and my father are one
the tatvam asi the
sachit ananda the wadat al-wujud
the dow that can be named is not the
eternal dao
you can imagine all of these concepts in
a lattice work
and revisiting them
and having a minor
better understanding and then revisiting
them again a couple months later
after doing more self-inquiry and more
self-inquiry and more self-inquiry and
more self-inquiry and getting even more
serious about the self-inquiry
and getting even more serious about
non-dual awareness and getting even more
serious about the importance of
self-realization
and what the most important spiritual
figures that have ever lived before us
today
are talking about tasting
and experientially tasting that
myself
taste it yourself
there's no better thing to taste
it's a well of honey that is
under the rock
and this is what true simultaneity is
simultaneity is key the ability to ebb
and flow
seamlessly frictionlessly harmonically
gracefully wisely and with unconditional
love
from the physical to the absolute
just yesterday fasting
laying down on the couch
just completely in a state of i
am the witness and then
doing these reps
practicing that agentless
attributeless formless indescribable
perfection of the absolute
and just how that indescribable
perfection the taste
channels through
to everything in the i am to everything
in the waves
every one of the clouds every one of the
words every one of the applications
every single experience thought feeling
emotion
belief object everything is divine
everything is indescribable
perfection simply this
to be able to ebb and flow
true simultaneity
is key
foreign
and if you're still in some of the more
contracted states
the egoic separate entity
ask yourself the question
is me
simply being conscious
is that not enough
is my awareness in itself
not majestic enough
shall i not drop my jaw to the
profundity
of this
and when you accept yourself and when
you love yourself
and when you recognize the juxtaposition
between
the i am ocean
and the waves of experience
and you gravitate more and more to that
i
am witness your
egoic separate entity
sugar cube dissolves
in the hot tea of
infinity
this is not to say that you do not get
to keep your beautiful
individuation because you do that
is your iris
your unique individuation
your unique creative expression
but it comes from a place of non-dual
awareness
a place of knowing
all right master this
master the ebbing and flowing
from that physical to that absolute
master the subtlety
it's key master the subtlety
i love you thank you
appreciate you
again let me know where you're at in the
comments we'd love to hear from you
like the video please share the video
with people that you think would find
this
profound and influential
subscribe if you haven't please
we have a lot of epic projects
that we're working on in 2021 and beyond
so if you'd like to support
those projects in our channel you can
find those links in the bio below
ah
that subtlety
prioritize self-realization
recognize the
diamond necklace that is already around
your neck
you